غالبًا ما يميل أطفال الماسون إلى تجاهل أمهاتهم
عن قصد ولكن لا
يقول الماسون مرحبًا في 18 شهرًا ، لقد حصل للتو على
معيناته السمعية الأولى
، شاهده وهو يسمع أمي
بوضوح لأول مرة ،
هل تسمعني مرحباً يا عزيزي ،
هل يمكنك سماع؟
خلف الكاميرا كانت
والدته لورين ويب تصرخ في المرة الأولى التي سمعني فيها
أقول اسمه عندما أضاء وجهه
هكذا لم أستطع الاحتفاظ به
معًا ، أعتقد أنني كنت بالتأكيد
أكثر سعادة مما كان رد فعله على الإنترنت كان
مشابهًا
سأعود حالاً بينما أذهب أبكي ، عمل جيد ،
نعم ، يمكنك سماعي ،
نعم ، لكنك لم تسمع القصة الكاملة
ولد ماسون قبل أربعة أشهر تقريبًا من
ابني الكبير بعد أن
اقتحم ثلاثة رجال مكان أمي وأبي في غزو عشوائي
للمنزل
انتهى بي الأمر  بعد إطلاق النار عليه ثلاث مرات
بعد يومين ، دخل لورين في
مخاض طارئ
يزن رطلًا واحدًا اعتقد الأطباء أن
ماسون قد لا ينجو
وقد يكون أعمى وقد لا يمشي أبدًا لكنه
تغلب على الصعاب وقد تم تزويده الآن
بمعينات سمعية في فيرجينيا
ج  مستشفى جامعة أومونويلث في
ريتشموند
، حتى أنهم أعطوه الأسد
المحشو المجهز بمساعدات سمعية
وهو يفعل الكثير مثل الصراخ
والضوضاء فقط لأنه الآن نوعًا ما
مثل المرة الأولى التي يمكنه فيها حتى سماع
نفسه بوضوح
ولكن حتى السمع لا يفعل ذلك.  تساعدني عندما
تخطو أمي بعيدًا
عندما تركتك يومًا ما ، فلماذا
سأبدأ اليوم
يومًا ما سينظر ماسون إلى الوراء ويستمع
إلى الكلمات الأولى التي سمعها بوضوح من
شفتي والدته ،
هل تحب كيف يبدو كل شيء ، على
الرغم من أن جودة الصوت تميل إلى
التحسن عندما
ضع السماعات في أذنيك
وليس فمك ماسون لا لا لا لا
لا رفيق جينيموس سي إن إن
نيويورك